[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
abend im olympiastadion von moskau ließ
sich wladimir putin heute feiern und
betrieb vor jubelndem publikum die
bereits bekannte kreml propaganda vom
angeblichen völkermord gegen den seine
armee in der ukraine
kämpferisch und erfolgreich derweil geht
das tatsächliche völkermorden in der
ukraine weiter und die russische armee
präsentiert sich dabei wieder heroisch
noch so erfolgreich wie putin ist
darstellt am boden kommen die russischen
truppen vielerorts nicht wirklich voran
sie schlagen vor allem aus der luft zu
kamera safari an berichtet über die
entwicklungen des tages
ganze wohnblöcke liegen in schutt und
asche
luftangriffe heute erneut in der
hauptstadt kiew raketen reisten die
menschen in einem wohnviertel im
nordwesten der stadt aus dem schlaf es
gab eine explosion wir warten auf
versteckten uns im bad dann rannten wir
raus
bürgermeister klitschko peilt zum
anschlagsort und will zeigen die raketen
treffen zivile ziele
dort ist ein kindergarten an dieser
seite eine schule sechs häuser stehen
hier sie sehen ja wie sie jetzt aus
bomben auf kiews organisierte jubel in
moskau tausende feiern ihren präsidenten
heute im luschniki-stadion putin
rechtfertigt die militärische
spezialoperationen der ukraine
inszeniert sich als heilsbringer
wir wollen das leiden der menschen und
den völkermord dort beenden das ist das
ziel der militäroperationen im dom bass
und der ukraine
beweise liefert er keine und plötzlich
reißt die übertragung ab
stattdessen sind ein bekannter schlager
sänger eine panne so der kreml
während putin sich feiert fallen auch in
der west ukraine bomben feuer und rauch
über lemberg ein wartungswerk in der
nähe des flughafens geht in flammen auf
viele menschen sind das umkämpften
gebieten nach lembeck geflüchtet um
schutz zu suchen am zentralen platz
stehen heute 109 leerer kinderwagen in
gedenken an getötete kinder im krieg
diese kinderwagen sind für kinder die
aus sehr gefährlichen orten kommen
einige von ihnen werden hier nie
ankommen weil sie schon tot sind
am abend dann erreichen uns diese bilder
aus mario pohl der krieg in der ukraine
geht unvermindert weiter sagte
was die zweitgrößte stadt der ukraine
neben mario pohl eine der am heftigsten
umkämpften und bombardierten von dort
ist uns die juristin und
politikwissenschaftlerin maria auf dem
zugeschalteten amt maria
findest du mich eingeladen haben wir
danken dass sie sich die zeit genommen
haben das risiko eingehen wie ist die
situation momentan krake führen dass das
die ganze zeit permanent bombardiert
wird wie erleben sie das
die letzten drei tage haben sie
bewegung erlebt
russland importiert uns nicht
generiert
und das universitätsgebäude gestört
haben
eine neue zerstörung leute zerstörte
häuser
wohngebiete das heißt die menschen die
dort wohnen wissen nicht mehr wo sie
wohnen und sie wissen nicht ob sie
zurückkehren kann in die wohnungen oder
ob sie sich in irgendwelchen schutzräume
begeben nicht wenn die u-bahn ich
brauche selber in der u bahn station und
habe gesehen dass manche familien mit
kindern jetzt schon mehr als drei wochen
leben
also auf dem boden schlafen irgendwelche
teppiche ausgerollt haben und
freiwillige bringen eben das essen die
situation ist wirklich sehr schwierig
die der beschluss war heute besonders
intensiv ich habe es heute nicht
geschafft einkaufen zu gehen um die ecke
war als ich rausgegangen
das plakatieren an und ich bin zurück
hätten die wohnung haben auch gerade
bilder gesehen die sie selbst gedreht
haben die sie uns geschickt haben sie
sagten sie sind nicht zum einkaufen
gekommen ist denn überhaupt noch genug
nahrung und wasser in der stadt in maria
poll hört man ist das ein schon gar
nicht mehr der fall gibt es das noch in
charkiw
anders als in mariupol weilt aktiven
möchte blockiert wird und man wollte
eine lokale
aber
das hat sich zerschlagen ersten tagen
der invasion die russischen truppen
wurden gestoppt im norden und nordosten
völker hat und
man kann dort nicht weiter
gegen
die hessische gedrängt eine große grenze
dass der süden und westen
sind eigentlich über straßen man kann
also dort von dort aus der stadt kommen
und die straßen sind als völlig sicher
das heißt wenn man auf der straße fährt
dann kann man auch selber zielscheibe
wird von einem raketenangriff oder einen
zuschuss weil überall geschossen nicht
nur bestimmen
aber es gibt immer noch zum ford straße
hilfe rief und verschiedene produkte
stadt liefern die natürlich damit große
risiken eingehen und das material in die
stadt bringen aber wenn man dann raus
wie man sich was einkaufen zu gehen dann
hat man ein risiko denn wir haben gehört
von leuten die sich wasser holen wollten
und auf der straße erschossen worden
sind
ich danke euch sehr für das gespräch und
achten sie gut auf sich
dass sie mich eingeladen haben
unsere sprechende aufgezeichnet es sind
menschen die maria fd war die
dokumentieren was in ihrem städten
geschieht damit die welt davon erfährt
in dem moment wo es den russischen
truppen gelingt ganze orte unter ihre
kontrolle zu bringen suchen sie nach
solchen menschen als erstes sowie auch
nach lokalen politikern oder
journalisten die verschleppt werden auf
besatzung folgt säuberung auch deshalb
kämpfen die ukraine so unglaublich mutig
weil sie wissen was geschieht wenn sie
sich ergeben
das wissen sie auch im nachbarland
velaros wo die opposition mit hilfe
moskaus so brutal niedergeschlagen wurde
diktator lukaschenka hat sich mit gedeih
und verderb putin ausgeliefert sein land
diente mit als aufmarschgebiet
eigene bilder russische truppen hatte er
laut westlichen geheimdiensten bisher
aber noch nicht in den krieg geschickt
zugleich hofft die belarussische
opposition verzweifelt darauf dass die
ukraine standhält das gebe auch ihr neue
hoffnung dara hassanzadeh ist für uns in
der ukraine und hat dort weder russische
oppositionelle getroffen die jetzt mobil
machen sie wollen nicht nur zusehen sie
wollen mit kämpfen für die ukraine und
für sich
wir treffen war die prokofjew er ist
eine der schlüsselfiguren in der bella
russischen opposition er will der
protestbewegung einen militärischen arm
geben eine belarussische exil armee in
der ukraine aufbauen diese soll an der
seite der ukraine gegen russland kämpfen
und damit indirekt auch gegen putins
verbündeten lukaschenko in minsk
alle strategien der bälle russischen
opposition
haben keine bedeutung
wenn die ukraine diesen krieg verliert
dann wird es in belarus für lange zeit
keine freiheit
wenn die ukraine diesen krieg gewinnt
und ich hoffe wir tragen unseren teil
bei dann haben wir eine chance unser
land zu befreien
schon jetzt kämpfen über 200
belarussische freiwillige in einheiten
der ukrainischen armee diese kämpfer
will war dem verein der belarussische
oberst ade sascha stück wird sie führen
und belarussischen opposition centre
bell satt wie für alle soldaten in
belarus auf nicht auf der seite
russlands zu kämpfen zu debattieren
mit ihm auf unserer seite werden wir das
hoffe ich eine große bälle russische
armee unter dem dach der ukrainischen
streitkräfte aufbauen ich beabsichtige
ein sammelbecken zu werden für viele
viele bälle russen und ein
einflussreicher faktor für unseren sieg
in linz managen center for the future
factory in minsk
die ersten offiziere sind bereits in der
ukraine ehemalige kämpfer bälle
russische spezialeinheiten geflüchtet
aus dem land die kaserne und ein
großteil der ausrüstung stellt die
ukrainische armee rekrutierung und
ausbildung ist ihre aufgabe
innerhalb eines trainingstages können
wir erkennen ob es sich um einen
militärisch motivierten amateur oder um
einen echten kämpfer handelt und wir
werden auch unsere soldaten haben die
jetzt schon für die ukraine an der front
kämpft
fresh from the front
seit tag drei des krieges agiert war die
maus dem untergrund er weiß dass er von
bella russischen geheimdienst gesucht
wird
nach wie vor gibt es auch internationale
diplomatische bemühungen bundeskanzler
scholz hat heute erneut mit putin eine
stunde telefoniert und ihn zu einem
waffenstillstand aufgerufen das blieb
wohl ähnlich ergebnislos wie das
telefonat dass emanuel marco mit dem
russischen präsidenten später am
nachmittag führt letztlich geht es darum
gesprächskanäle aufrechtzuerhalten damit
der kontakt nicht gänzlich abbricht
außerdem gab es heute das mit spannung
erwartete gespräch zwischen us-präsident
beiden und chinas präsident hu wie sich
die chinesen zu diesem krieg
positionieren könnte am ende sogar
ausschlaggebend dafür sein wie lange er
dauert und wie er ausgeht
fräulein peking wie ulf interpretiert du
das was von dem verlauf des gesprächs
bisher bekannt geworden ist
es ist ja ganz interessant im vorfeld
des gesprächs hatten sich amerika und
die chinesen noch mal richtig kräftigen
verbalen schlagabtausch geliefert haben
sich gegenseitig mit sanktionen bedroht
und wenn man jetzt nach zwei stunden
gegen das gespräch zwischen beiden und
sie die abschlusserklärung der chinesen
liest ist das doch alles im ton
wesentlich moderator und freundlicher
sie hat noch mal daran erinnert dass
beide länder amerika und china quasi
eine verpflichtung haben einen frieden
zu finden aber in der sache hat sie
nicht irgendwie erkennen lassen wie er
das machen will die politik der chinesen
bleibt auch nach diesen zwei stunden
weiter widersprüchlich china ist auf der
einen seite gegen diesen krieg und sagt
sie unterstützen die ukraine auf der
anderen seite sind sie aber auch für
russland ich glaube was china so
versucht ist ein mittelweg man will sich
mit dem westen nicht anlegen man braucht
den westen als wirtschaftsblock da ist
sehr wichtig für china andererseits
braucht man russland geostrategisch und
deshalb versucht man so eine neutrale
position sei ich glaube überhaupt dass
china nur dann die seiten wechselt wenn
es sieht dass putin wirklich anmacht
substanziell verliert sonst wird das
nicht passieren
die us amerikanischen geheimdienste
vermuten oder haben das zumindest gesagt
dass in china russland längst
unterstützt militärisch aber das geheim
halten will
ja das ist eine schwierige frage das
wirklich zu beantworten und letztendlich
weiß ich das nicht wir wissen ja dass
mit geheimdienstinformationen auch gerne
mal politik gemacht wird wir erinnern
uns dran damals im irak krieg die
massenvernichtungswaffen von saddam
hussein das hat nicht gestimmt
gleichzeitig gilt auch dass die
amerikanischen geheimdienste
doch im vorfeld des krieges ukraine
krieges sehr sehr gut über die russische
armee informiert waren also das ist sehr
schwierig zu beurteilen biden hat in dem
gespräch noch mal sehr deutlich gemacht
wenn die chinesen waffen liefern
überschreiten sie eine rote linie und
müssen mit bitteren konsequenzen rechnen
und ich habe das gefühl dass china daran
kein interesse hat ich erlebe china sehr
sehr vorsichtig in seinen unterstützung
von russland man will den westen nicht
wirklich provozieren deswegen glaube ich
dass man das am ende wahrscheinlich
nicht macht weil dieser krieg eher ein
problem für china ist weil dieser krieg
eigentlich 1 erreicht hat putin damit
dass das westliche bündnis so stark und
so beschlossen ist wie noch nie zuvor
und das will china nicht deswegen glaube
ich am ende ist die solidarität mit
russland eher eine rhetorische und keine
die wirklich substanziell wirtschaftlich
oder auch militärisch ist danke schön
rief nach peking für die analyse und
jetzt erstmal heinz wolf mit anderen
nachrichten des tages
außenministerin berbalk hat angesichts
des russischen krieges in der ukraine
die deutsche bereitschaft zu einem
stärkeren internationalen engagement für
frieden und sicherheit unterstrichen zum
start der arbeit an einer neuen
nationalen sicherheitsstrategie für
deutschland sagte berg in berlin
russlands aggressives vorgehen führe vor
augen bei fragen von krieg und frieden
bei fragen von recht und unrecht könne
kein land auch nicht deutschland neutral
sein dies gelte besonders an der
deutschen geschichte
us-verteidigungsminister osten ist heute
zu einem zweitägigen besuch nach
bulgarien gereist und war zuvor in der
slowakei und kam am nachmittag in sofia
an zunächst waren gespräche mit dem
bulgarischen verteidigungsminister
vorgesehen und für morgen dann ein
treffen mit ministerpräsident pat cox
das bulgarische außenministerium gab
heute bekannt dass zehn russische
diplomaten zu unerwünschten personen
erklärt worden sein sie müssten das land
binnen 72 stunden verlassen
die russische botschaft in sofia
reagierte mit empörung und kündigte eine
baldige reaktion an
der bundestag hat die verlängerung von
drei auslandseinsätzen der bundeswehr
zugestimmt somit kann sich deutschland
für ein weiteres jahr an der
nato-operation sie guardian zur
überwachung des mittelmeers beteiligen
und ebenfalls um ein jahr verlängert
wurde die bundeswehr beteiligung an der
un mission im südsudan zum schutz von
zivilisten und zur unterstützung des
friedensprozesses dort
zur krone situation in deutschland der
omicron subtyp baa2 weitet sich dem
robert koch institut zufolge weiter aus
ein grund für den derzeitigen anstieg
der zahlen das rkw melde 297
1845 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
45.000 neun mehr als vor einer woche
226 todesfälle kamen hinzu sieben tage
incidents liegt bei rund 1700 6
die hohen infektionszahlen sind
allenthalben zu spüren kaum ein
unternehmen das keinen personalausfälle
wegen corona hat und auch wenn bei
omikron und dank der impfungen die
verläufe weniger schwer sind es ist auch
nicht so als hätte man in den
krankenhäusern gerade langeweile auch
auf den normalen stationen liegen viele
corona patienten zugleich sind dort auch
viele mitarbeitende krank oder in
quarantäne
vor diesem hintergrund wurde der
politische streit über das auslaufen
praktisch aller maßnahmen zuletzt ja
immer schärfer auch innerhalb der ampel
koalition im bundestag ließ sich das
heute trefflich beobachten berichte
teilt das land gehen es wirkt wie ein
stück aus dem tollhaus die liberalen die
den freedom day versprochen hatten gegen
spd und grüne die zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
eigentlich gegen lockerungen sind ihr
gesetz zur pandemie bekämpfung ein
mühsamer kompromiss
das ist das was innerhalb der ampel
vereinbar war und worst case wäre
gewesen alle schutzmaßnahmen auslaufen
zu lassen wir haben wahnsinnig hohe
fallzahlen aber auch heute wieder wenn
sie auf den export gehen sehen sie das
auch wieder die intensivpatienten die
zahl abgenommen hat der kleinste
gemeinsame nenner nach gerade mal 100
tagen im amt der
bundesgesundheitsminister seit zwei
jahren als warner der nation aufgefallen
nun verteidigt er ein gesetz das einen
geringen basis schutz verspricht und bei
hotspots die verantwortung an die länder
delegiert eine kehrtwende wir können
nicht weiter das gesamte land unter
schutz stellen um eine kleine gruppe von
impfwilligen
und denjenigen die beraten nicht bereit
sind die massnahmen mitzutragen um diese
zu schützen
handwerklich schlecht gemacht sei das
gesetz so die union zu wenig instrumente
zu unpräzise nicht praktikabel doch
manch einer ist für öffnungen andere
länder in europa haben viel früher
geöffnet doch der minister beschwört mit
vorliebe unseren angeblich schlecht in
corona status die länder sind sauer
überrumpelt nicht eingebunden das
umstrittene gesetz nicht einmal
zustimmungspflichtig dabei müssen sie es
am ende um setzen man kann nicht
gleichzeitig den ländern die
handwerkszeuge aus der hand nehmen und
sie gleichwohl für die bekämpfung der
pandemie verantwortlich machen das geht
nicht
ein gesetz zum schutz der bevölkerung
wird in einer woche durchgepeitscht
vorerst gilt für die meisten länder eine
zweiwöchige übergangsfrist danach
könnten die meisten corinna regeln
wegfallen
was für die einen der ersehnte freedom
day ist ist für andere ein horror für
menschen die schwer erkrankt sind die
häufig medikamente nehmen müssen durch
die eine impfung nicht wirkt für diese
menschen war die pandemie bisher schon
entschuldigung besonders hart längst hat
sich für die betroffenen und ihre
angehörigen ein eigener begriff geprägt
schatten familien
von denen manche seit über zwei jahren
kaum noch das haus verlassen haben wenn
jetzt was alle maßnahmen fallen steigen
für sie die risiken wir haben eine
solche familie besucht virtuell
natürlich werden ja nicht selbst bei ihm
drehen können sie haben selbst gefilmt
und uns ihre videos geschickt
trockenboden sie betreut ein
pieks zum blutzuckermessen das ist nena
elf jahre jung nena wurde ohne nieren
geboren mit 5 bekam sie ein spenderorgan
ihr immunsystem ist extrem schwach das
alles ist schon schwer genug und seit
zwei jahren hat nena kaum noch kontakt
zur außenwelt
die ganze familie lebt seit zwei jahren
in isolation keine freunde treffen keine
schule kein kino für die meisten sind
die jüngsten lockerungs pläne ein grund
zum feiern für jasmine jost er nicht
wie soll ich mein kind weiter schützen
wenn draußen auf einmal der freedom day
kommt wenn das keine maßnahmen mehr gibt
denn selbst die beste mal was ich
anziehen kann schützt nicht 100 prozent
und je höher die erosion belastung in
einem supermarkt ist je höher da die
viruslast ist desto wahrscheinlicher ist
es dass einer von uns irgendwann mit
nach hause bringt nena wurde geimpft
aber der wirkstoff wird bei ihr nicht
richtig medikamente die sie nehmen muss
verhindern dass familie just führt ein
leben abseits des normalen alltags ein
leben als sogenannte schatten familie
das sind familien mit schwerkranken
kindern die seit beginn der pandemie aus
großer sorge vor einer infektion ihr
gesandt des gesellschaftliches leben
eingefroren haben die gar nicht nach
draußen gehen und
diese familien sind tatsächlich die
verlierer der pandemie der alltag ist
anstrengend für familie ist lena braucht
viel pflege der 19 jährige sohn studiert
online verlässt auch sonst kaum noch das
haus alles aus sorge nena zu infizieren
freundschaften sind daran zerbrochen
hinzu kommen finanzielle sorgen dass
lius ehefrau hat ihren job in der pflege
aufgegeben zu viele soziale kontakte zu
viele möglichkeiten sich mit corona zu
infizieren wir haben jetzt im prinzip in
den letzten zwei jahren ein großteil
unserer reserven die wir davor hatten
aufgebraucht inklusive altersvorsorge
muss man ganz einfach sagen
es geht mir schlecht das recht ja man
guckt dass wir über die runden kommen
auch beim kinderarzt oder in der
kinderklinik fühlt sich die familie
nicht mehr wohl weil es eltern im
wartezimmer zu oft mit der masken
pflicht doch nicht so genau nehmen mit
anderen kindern spielt nina nur online
und spaziergänge wie dieser sind die
absolute ausnahme
sie fängt an zu vergessen wie es vorher
war und das ist was was ich wirklich
erschreckend finde dass sie so dieses
leben das sie jetzt führt schon fast als
normal betrachtet und das sollte
eigentlich nicht sein andere sehnen sich
nach mehr freiheiten vielleicht
entspannt ein bier zu trinken mit
freunden familie jost lebt weiter in
angst angst um jene die einfach mal
wieder einkaufen gehen möchte
und jetzt nochmal ein zweiter mit
anderen themen
die wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen des
russischen einmarsches in der ukraine
sind in deutschland in verschiedenen
bereichen zu spüren so schließt heute
der hauptverband der deutschen
bauindustrie
baustopps für viele projekte nicht mehr
aus von bethmann was heißt das für die
baubranche na ja viele bauvorhaben
verzögern sich weiter obwohl der
wohnraum ja dringend benötigt wird also
da sind geplant 400.000 wohnungen in
diesem jahr zu bauen von der
ampelkoalition neue wohnungen mit blick
auf die flüchtlingskatastrophe gibt es
erste schätzungen dass es sogar eher
rund 500.000 braucht vor allem an
bezahlbaren wohnungen fehlt es und das
nicht erst seit gestern
da aber wo etwas knapp ist floriert das
geschäft 20 21 war das erfolgreichste
jahr unserer unternehmensgeschichte
bilanzierte heute wohnen wo novia chef
rolf buch bei der vorstellung der
jahresbilanz wo novia ist deutschlands
größtes wohnungsunternehmen der
dax-konzern ist nicht nur erfolgreich
sondern auch umstritten vor allem bei
vielen mietern der blick auf die
statistik verrät warum im vergangenen
jahr verteuerte sich der wohnraum für wo
novia mieter im schnitt auf 7 eur 33 pro
quadratmeter das waren 2,4 prozent mehr
als noch im jahr zuvor wo nur via
investierte und modernisierte verdiente
aber auch gut an den gestiegenen mieten
bei wichtigen kennzahlen will der
immobilien konzern nach eigenen angaben
nun weiter um mehr als 20 prozent
wachsen anleger hören so etwas gerne
mieter eher weniger denn weitere
gewinnsprünge dürften ohne weitere
mieterhöhungen kaum realisierbar sein
konkret man vielen dank
das spiel in der fußball bundesliga
zwischen bochum und gladbach ist wegen
eines becherwurfs auf den
schiedsrichter-assistenten in der 68
minute beim stand von 0 2 abgebrochen
worden das schiedsrichtergespann zog
sich daraufhin in die katakomben zurück
über den genauen gesundheitszustand des
schiedsrichter-assistenten ist bisher
nichts bekannt
das ergebnis der auslosung für das
viertelfinale in der champions league
lautet für bayern münchen gegner ist
spaniens fc villarreal im viertelfinale
der europa league trifft eintracht
frankfurt auf den fc barcelona und rb
leipzig spielt gegen atalanta bergamo
zum auftrag des biathlon weltcup finales
in oslo gab es für das deutsche team
keinen platz auf dem podest im sprint
der männer kamen aber vier deutsche
unter die top 8 wobei benedikt doll als
vierter der beste war den tagessieg
sicherte sich der norweger sturla hall
blade für einzel olympiasiegerin denise
herrmann reichte es zu platz sieben
franziska hildebrand wurde neunte
die us-raumfahrtbehörde nasa hat ihr
neues raketensystem für den abflug
richtung mond bereitgemacht der
spezialtransporter wurde die 98 meter
hohe rakete zur startrampe in cape
canaveral in florida gebracht zunächst
noch ohne besatzung soll die rakete
frühestens im mai als test flug zum mond
starten mit der artemis mission will die
nasa 2025 wieder astronauten auf den
mond bringen darunter sollen erstmals
auch eine frau sein
wer sich an die erste mondlandung
inhalts erinnert sich auch noch an die
jahrzehnte des ersten kalten krieges und
an den beginn der neuen ostpolitik unter
willy brandt und an einen seiner
wichtigsten berater und vordenker egon
bahr der heute 100 jahre alt geworden
wäre wandel durch annäherung war ein
schlagwort das er prägte der
grundgedanke dahinter wenn wir die
berliner mauer schon nicht durchbrechen
können dann wenigstens durchlässiger
machen entspannungs politik war für ihn
allerdings weniger idealismus als
nüchterner interessenausgleich gerade
heute wo wir das gefühl haben die
geschichte dreht sich rasend schnell
rückwärts lohnt sich ein blick zurück
den wirft für uns peter kurz
seine formel der deutschen entspannungs
politik der gegenentwurf zum kalten
krieg
staatssekretär egon bahr war der
architekt von wandel durch annäherung
willy brandt baute darauf seine
kanzlerschaft wir wollen ein volk der
guten nachbarn sein und werden im innern
und nach außen gewalt verzichtserklärung
mit der sowjetunion anerkennung der
grenzen breschnjew brands gorbatschow
kohl und die wiedervereinigung
deutschlands wurde der blick verklärt
durch eine rosarote brille
diese idee die sowjetunion in
irgendeiner weise wieder zu beleben oder
großmacht ideen wiederzubeleben das sind
vielleicht ein paar ideologen aber das
wird nicht gerüstet sein mann übersah
schon 1991 gehörte wladimir putin zu
einem kleinen kreis alter kgb leute in
sankt petersburg die den zerfall der
sowjetunion nicht einfach hinnehmen
wollten als putin 2001 im bundestag dem
westen sicherheitskooperation auf
augenhöhe anbot war das vielleicht die
letzte chance auf annäherung zu
akzeptieren so schwer es fällt dass
diese idee von dem gemeinsamen haus und
das was man vor zwei jahren noch gedacht
hat den freundschaft dass das nicht
funktioniert und wird zumindest auf
mittlere frist dass man aber eben in
gewisser weise zu stabilen verhältnissen
kommen muss der kurzes tänzchen das ist
völlig auch die grundidee von lang durch
anhänger stattdessen aber gegenseitige
abwendung der westen genoss die sieger
rolle nach dem kalten krieg und amerika
ließ putin geringschätzung spüren
rascher
russland ist eine regionale macht die
ein paar direkte nachbarn bedroht
mails von der man allerdings trotzdem
gern nahm was sie an öl und gas günstig
anbot handel war gut der wandel des
mannes im kreml wurde ignoriert
was jetzt passiert soll die dominanz des
westens beenden wirtschaftlich wie
politisch so putin seit dieser woche
vom gefühlten katzentisch reist ein in
seinem ego getroffener neuer
250 jahre europäische
sicherheitsarchitektur 1 wir werden am
ende auch wieder verhandeln müssen aber
in einer anderen art und weise gilt das
gleiche wie in der entspannungs politik
der 16 70er jahre sie müssen stark sein
wenn der andere sie für schwach hält für
zerstritten für unfähig eine gemeinsame
haltung hat dann wird er nicht
verhandeln spannung statt entspannung
auf stadt abrüsten putin hat der welt
sein spiel aufgezwungen sein update von
russisch roulette
das was von uns gleich nach dem wetter
geht es weiter mit der heute show und
gegen 0.30 dann unser heute-journal
update mit hanna zimmermann bis morgen
auf wiedersehen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend nach einer meist klare nacht
bei temperaturen von plus 5 bis minus 2
grad scheint morgen im westen ordentlich
die sonne im osten sind die wolken
dichter und in den mittelgebirgen kann
es mal einige schauer geben am sonntag
kann es im äußersten südwesten mal einen
schauer geben danach aber dominiert
sonne die ist ja zurzeit ziemlich aktiv
donnerstag vergangener woche gab es
wieder eine große eruption auf der sonne
elektronen protonen und alpha teilchen
werden in einer plasmawolke mit großer
geschwindigkeit richtung erde
geschleudert wir nennen das auch
sonnenwind der trifft auf das
erdmagnetfeld und verformt es die plasma
teilchen werden in richtung pole gelenkt
und regen dort die luftpartikel zum
leuchten an bei uns auf der
nordhalbkugel heißen sie nordlichter
aurora borealis normalerweise sind sie
weit im norden in der nähe des
polarkreises zu sehen zum beispiel im
norden von island norwegen schweden und
findet bei uns in mitteleuropa werden
sie dagegen äußerst selten gesichtet
ralph meier sind anfang der woche auf
sylt diese faszinierenden zeitraffer
aufnahmen gelungen die farben hängen
damit zusammen ob sauerstoff oder
stickstoff johnen zum leuchten angeregt
werden und in welcher höhe das passiert
zumeist hunderte kilometer über unseren
köpfen
schönes wochenende